this impression got out there how is it
that you are less popular than your
party that even your own MPs consider
you a liability how has that happened
look I don't commentate on these things
I don't comment on these things read
them no I think that's better I
definitely don't read them do you read
about yourself not if I can avoid
exactly exactly that you make my point
for me
look ah there's six weeks to go till the
general election the people here the
people at home will make up their mind
about me and about the country and what
kind of country they want but you know
frankly it is water off a duck's back
honestly
so when because Simon Dan Chuck says I
find when I go and stand on the doorstep
ed miliband is a liability you are
unaware of that look some dancers invite
entitled to his views but the only thing
I can do the thing I've learnt most of
this job let me tell you is to be
yourself right that's what I am and you
know people have to decide do they want
my ideas do they want my principles when
I stood up to it not just the president
obama but rupert murdoch the energy
companies the banks fighting for
ordinary people which is what i believe
in what i came into politics for and do
they want somebody who will think every
day about how they put working people
first in our country and you know i
don't care what the newspapers write
about me because what i care about is
what's happened to the british people
and i know this country can be so much
better and that's what i came into
politics for and newspapers can write
what they like the bloke on the tube can
say what he likes I don't care because I
care about the British people and what
happens to them the thing is they see
was a North London geek who cares